jacquet votre pilule ça ne marche pas ma
femme ne lui toujours pas et m'a emmené
nous simples liberta vous savez ce coup
c'est pour lui faire plaisir je me suis
hills est touchée par des mecs là ce qui
nous concerne nous attaquer c'est le
début de la descente aux enfers c'est
plutôt bien démarré la partie comme
j'étais prête à supporter tous ces cons
pourvu qu'ils me fila maxdb une vieille
psy qui héberge une candeur son papier
soit rationnelle je sais pas tu n'auras
jamais d'enfant je sais que je peux
tomber enceinte jacky alcatel à danone
mais voilà les meilleures histoires su
le juge martin sont celles qui nous
emmène à la cie attend pas fred peslier
de prétendent pas savoir où sont ses 50
millions
vous êtes la meilleure dans le milieu
des crapules vous avez trois jours
complets de boutiques que je suis son
entame en aide
ça pue le fric où tous les côtés
jacqueline j'espère que tu es conscient
de ce que tu en train de faire un vrai
schmilblick
finalement tu t'en fous y'a que ta
boutique on encore je sais par contre
c'est depuis hier mon fils tout le monde
passait à côté du magot tous passés par
comploteurs petit manège avec ce petit
village akli de nos communes ah oui
cb
plus tôt on respecte
monté avec jack black metal
photo co dia